Democrats going ballistic over who
should have a say in the classroom the
house just passed the GOP bill called
the parents Bill of Rights which
guarantees mothers and fathers access to
certain information about their
children's schools not a single Democrat
voted for it instead they lobbed some
serious claims about it
don't we want our children to know that
slavery was wrong as I fight against
slavery today that still exists bills
like this make schools more hostile and
make no mistake it results in hate
bigotry and yes sometimes death of our
students we need more politicians
reading Generals in America and fewer
politicians trying to censor books in
America dream Mega Republicans don't
want the Children of America to learn
about
the Holocaust when we talk about
Progressive values I can say what my
Progressive value is and that is freedom
over fascism
she said it Freedom over fascism but
here's what's actually inside that bill
it guarantees mothers and fathers the
right to know what is being taught bring
concerns to officials see budgets
protect privacy and get updates about
any violence happening in the school
Republicans say all they're trying to do
is Empower parents
today was a win for every mother every
father but most importantly for every
student in America
you have a parent's Bill of Rights now
but unfortunately the Democrats are too
extreme to believe that parents should
have a say in their kids education and
all of us here today are proud to say we
as House Republicans sided with parents
having a right to be involved in their
kids education and if the Democrats are
going to be too extreme as they show
they are today we're going to continue
to fight for them anyway judge what what
what do Democrats have issue with here I
mean knowing what books are on the
shelves in your school library finding
out what's in the budget finding out if
there's any violence happening in the
schools learning more about the
curriculum happening in the classroom
what are they taking issue with here
well I think what they're taking issue
with a lot of it has to do with things
that parents obviously don't want their
kids to know about that is like gender
affirming care like we don't want kids
under the age of 18 to have this kind of
conversation with their with the school
teachers unless the parents are involved
that means puberty blockery blockers
hormone therapy surgical procedures but
look let's back up a minute these kids
are our kids we pay the teachers to
teach our kids they aren't doing us any
favors we think that money should go
with the child but they unfortunately
believe in this kind of socialist
Marxist you know life of Julia that
Obama described several years ago we
where it's the government that pays for
the kids it's a government that teaches
the kids it's government ideology which
is why we've got such craziness going on
in our country right now and it's why
yesterday we talked on the five about
the fact that you've got 35
000 teachers in Los Angeles on strike
not for themselves but in solidarity
with the school district with the I
think the the bus drivers and the
caretakers and the custodians I mean
they've got to start being in solidarity
with our kids and recognize that the
kids are ours they're not theirs and in
the end we need a reset because we found
out during the pandemic they were
teaching our kids I don't want my kids
or my grandchildren at this point to
actually see something and Jesse did it
on his show and I did it on my show of
sexual acts in in a book better that are
being given to seven-year-olds on how to
have sexual acts with someone of the
opposite gender or the same gender
that's not that's not American you know
not entitled to do it and who are you to
refuse to tell me what you're teaching
my kids Richard you're a Democrat uh
what is what is unreasonable about the
requests in this bill well look I I
think for a minute you have to put
partisanship aside and I urge everybody
to go to congress.gov and read this
32-page bill I did it was done
interesting reading
um and I think it's really important you
read the bill to understand what's in
there right because the bill does
there's things in the bill that I think
are good I think it's important for
folks to know what the school budget is
I think it's important for folks to have
a sense of what's in there but I think
what I found questionable about the bill
is Juan how do you it's enforcement
mechanisms how do folks enforces and two
in the idea of doing all these things
how are how do folks how do we plan on
paying for this like how are folks going
to pay for it wow that's a that would be
the first time Democrats asked that
question well no but I mean this listen
what this bill is mandating is for small
school systems rules school districts
all across the country to post all these
lists put all these things on the
internet mandating two times a year
parent conferences I think they should
do but how do you pay for this without
hiring a parent coordinator how do you
do it
all right first of all how much does it
cost to set up a parent-teacher
conference I'll do one right now dude
I think you're you're first of all I
think you're simplifying a very more
complex problem number one and number
two if we're having a conversations
about books and libraries it's worth
pointing out that 15 of America's Public
Schools don't have libraries and beyond
that since 2018 we've seen a precipitous
fall in the number of librarians in
schools all across the country my point
is here is if we're going to have a
conversation about how we fix our
schools we should also talk about the
resources going into our schools okay I
don't know instead of just labeling
bills as parent Bill of Rights when
they're not actually rights there's
plenty of money Richard we just like
drove as much money as possible down the
teachers Union's throats they're lying
Sandra they come out and say you're
getting taught in school that slavery
was right give me one example where
students are being taught that slavery
was right and then they say they're
trying to censor books yeah the books
with like let's act it out Greg yes
come closer yes
that's close enough
graphic sexual
positions acts yeah we want those Books
banned
what is that yeah we'll light it on fire
or at least put it in the adult library
or how about this they're not learning
about the Holocaust I mean everybody
learns about the Holocaust so you're
getting members of Congress straight up
lying and they can't even lie from their
heart they have to read the lies that
their staff wrote to them and this is
why it is impossible to have a
conversation with these people okay
because if you're just gonna lie and not
get called out on it then we can't ever
move forward yeah I always love the if
we're going to have a conversation if
we're going to have a conversation then
you have the conversation what do they
do they falsely accuse you of being a
domestic terrorist parents went to the
school boards to have a conversation and
what happened the FBI opened a probe on
them and then you know what happened
after that nothing there was Zero
evidence of a legitimate threat was that
reported on in the media only at Fox
House Republicans did it the media
didn't bother to follow up on these
threats they didn't try to find out who
these domestic terrorists were God
forbid they were they wanted to get
between you know get between their
teachers and their kids and do not fall
for the big lie about privacy when
they're when you hear you know grab your
kids who when a liberal activist says
we're concerned about a child's privacy
because what they're saying is they're
trying to get between you and your child
there is no privacy right children are
children right parents are in control of
their privacy they have to look out for
them don't pretend that like a
four-year-old is is this independent
being with its own privacy I didn't get
a lock on my door since until I was 15.
I never got one and even then you can
still pick it with a credit card here's
the deal right this is you know what are
my notes it's okay
by the way it's important not important
okay just right if you're gonna if
you're gonna School us on education
pronounce the DMT in importance all
right so here's the deal there's zero
evidence at all that there's any kind of
threat but they painted parents as
domestic terrorists they got away with
that right we can't let it happen again
the Republican party is becoming the
party for parents the Democratic party
is becoming the party of the unhappy
single female activist it has become the
party of Karen's the Republicans are now
the party of couples and children and
now they're being demonized because they
actually give a damn because they're
going to show up because they're going
to talk about it so do so this is I
think they realize that they're kind of
like up against the wall here they
backed the wrong horse sadly none of
that's in this Bill
yes I read the bill what's your favorite
part what was the most important if you
believe that you believe everything you
said there's no enforcement mechanism
in this bill to make everything you said
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else